This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
Statements in this program have not been
evaluated by the FDA. As an empowered
individual, you do have options
available or All
right.
Welcome to Daily with Doc and Beck.
This program is for educational purposes
only. The statements in this program
have not been evaluated by the FDA. The
content is not intended to diagnose,
treat, cure, or prevent any diseases,
nor is it intended to take the place of
your primary care physician.
Testimonials are shared as individual
experiences of the individual sharing
their testimony. Results vary and may
not be typical. We do not make any
claims regarding health or income. As an
empowered individual, you do have
options available. We are honored to
have the founding father of the science
of epigenetics guiding us with the best
options to obtain or maintain optimal
health, Dr. Joel Wallik.
Hello, hello everybody. Welcome to Daily
with Doc and Becca. My name is Becca
Dukes and we are so excited to have you
here as we are welcoming back to the
show Dr. Laura Dennis. She is a
naturopathic doctor who is dedicated and
has a passion for guiding people towards
vibrant health through natural
sciencebacked solutions. So folks, I
hope you are ready for an amazing
hour of learning because she is bringing
in a topic we don't talk a whole lot
about. So get your pens and be ready.
Now, just as a reminder, we are an
amazing
we are a resource. We are amazing, but
we are a resource for an amazing
community of certified holistic health
coaches. I'm super excited as I see many
of their names here on the um on the
screen and the participants. And folks,
this is a live Zoom. So, if you would
like to join us live, you're more than
welcome to do so. Go to
zoom.dailywithdoc.com
and make sure that you have your name on
the list by emailing us zoom
dailywithdoc.com
as we're going to be changing up a few
things. We want to make sure that those
who want to be here with great intent
have a special invitation and link to
join us. So again, we are live
Wednesday, Thursday, Friday from 12 to
1:00 p.m. Pacific, 1 to 2 Mountain, 2 to
3 Central, and 3 to 4 Eastern.
Also, if you were referred to this
program by somebody specific, they are
your person. They are your go-to person,
the person you want to get back to and
say, "Thank you for sharing this program
with me." And if you have any questions,
they're the first point of contact. If
they don't know the answers, they can
help refer you to somebody who does know
the answers. So, I just want to say a
hello and shout out as we have people
joining us on YouTube. Hello Harry,
hello AJ. Welcome, welcome. And here in
the Zoom, we have a number of
individuals. Barbara, Bruce, Corey,
um Sherry, Darlene, Donna, Kyrion, Mary,
Rod, hello and welcome, welcome,
welcome. So, let's go ahead folks.
And um I do have to say this program is
for educational purposes only. It's not
meant to take the place your primary
care physician, nor is it meant to
treat, diagnose, or cure any disease.
But body, when you give your body the
what it needs, the body itself can do
some amazing things. And that's more
about what you're going to learn about
today. Our specific topic,
let it flow. Actually, this is the
title, Let It Flow. Why a healthy
lymphatic system is essential for detox
and defense. Folks, the lymphatic system
was one of the body's most
underappreciated yet vital networks.
You're going to hear more about that
with the amazing
Dr. Laura Dennis. Hello, Dr. Laura. Let
me get you up the on the screen with me.
There you are. Hello, beautiful. Welcome
back.
>> Hello. Oh, I am so excited to be back
and oh my goodness, everybody on here
looks so beautiful and it's just a
beautiful day and so I'm so grateful and
thankful to be here.
>> Well, you know, we're thankful to be
here as well and seeing new names, new
faces come on with us um just helps us
know that the word is getting out
that we don't have to depend on a system
that's continually
keeping us sick.
Well, and and the topic that we're
talking about today is a lot of it
caused from our environment and a system
that is, you know, it's is it's against
us. And so, I'm glad that you were able
to have me do this topic today.
>> Well, I am I'm so thankful that I mean,
you gave me a list of topics and they
were all so fantastic and I'm like,
wait, we don't talk about the lymphatic
system very often, so let's go ahead and
do that. And folks, just a note, Dr.
Laura Dennison, she is a naturopathic
doctor.
She does take on clients and do
consultations with clients. And for you
that are coaches, you know, have people
that are wanting to to talk with a
doctor, Dr. Laura is one of our amazing
doctors that have we have the
opportunity to have the consult for our
clients and she then sends them back to
you the coach to help them place their
order. So, we just want to make sure
that we have that set. And for those who
are, is it in Young already? You do a
25% discount off your consultation.
>> Any referral from a Young Jevity coach,
Youngevity distributor. So, it could
even be a new client of theirs. They
don't necessarily have to be already
taken the products, but um any referral
I give that 25% off. And so, um, I do
give that coupon pretty freely. So, if
you are hearing it, guess what? Just put
the coupon in. You're going to get it.
>> Fantastic.
And you want to make sure folks, you
want to go to her website, Laura Dennis.
That's with two N's,
N D. So, L A U R A D E N I S O N
D.com.
And if you want more information, you
can go info at lauradend.com.
And her phone number, you want to send
her a text message, 580 3349627.
But you're still gonna have to go to the
website. So, Dr. Laura, um, anything you
want to add to that before we get diving
deep into today's topic?
>> Well, I do want to say that um, you
guys, I love being partnered with
Youngevity. And when I say that, you
guys, we don't have to go anywhere else.
And so it is a safe place when you send
your people or you know because I do so
many different um aspects of health you
know I it's not just supplementation you
have to have other things that and I
like I have a lot of natural therapies
that I also suggest and and we do a
wellness scan and so we go really in
deep um and in depth with a client and
so because the most important thing we
want is we want to get people healthy
right we want them
And um and so that's what I take a
passion about doing. And so thank you,
Becca, for sharing that with me today.
>> Oh, thank you for sharing the
information with us and your services.
So that just helps us help others. And
as we're we're doing that, you know,
we're just making healthier communities
around the world. And that's what I'm
all about. So let's go ahead and dig in
with
letting the system flow.
You know, I like that whole topic
because you guys, the lymphatic system
is so intricate and it's so, you know,
fascinating to me because you guys, the
lymphatic system, it has sort of like
little prongs, okay? And so our
lymphatic system is trying to help move
lymph through the body and rid your body
of toxins and also send the immune
system messages to go send um you know
to fight off defenders. And so our
lymphatic system is so important, but
it's the most under underappreciated.
And so when we have these prongs, we
have to have an upward motion to move
limp. Okay? And so for people that are,
you know, don't get around much, um,
people that, uh, are chronically sick,
um, people that, um, don't drink enough
water, you guys, a lot of this can
affect your lymphatic system. So, today
we're going to talk about how to have a
wellfunctioning lymphatic system, which,
you know, your lymphatic system runs
right along with your circulatory
system, but it also runs right along
with your detoxification pathways. And
so all three are critical things to stay
healthy. So why don't we talk about the
lymphatic system more? Because it's so
important. We don't talk about the
lymphatic system until you have like a
swollen lymph node, okay? And then all
of a sudden you get strep throat or an
ear ache or you know that's whenever you
you realize that you have a lymphatic
system. But you guys it's very crucial.
You know, I um was working with a client
and I can't tell details, but you know,
she has a serious condition that's
dependent on her lymphatic system and um
you know, with the swollen lymph nodes
and and so she's doing all these natural
therapies and things are going in the
right direction for her and it's
beautiful. But she is eating for her
lymphatic system. She is exercising for
her lymphatic system and she's
supplementing. And so there's so many
different things that you got to do and
and I excited to tell you about all of
it today. So let me know when you want
me to share my screen and I'll go ahead
and share that and we'll get started.
>> Go for it.
>> We are ready.
>> Okay. So like I said, the lymphatic
system is so intricate and it just
doesn't um operate without moving limp.
Okay? And so when we move limp, okay, it
has to go upward motion. And that's why
there's a lot of, you know, natural
things that we can do. Um, let me put
this on the slide.
There's a lot of natural things that we
can do as far as to help improve moving
lymph. Um, for instance, um, hot and
cold treatment, you know, going from hot
to cold stimulates the lymphatic system,
um, you know, to move limp. Uh, skin
brushing. Okay. Dry brushing. That's
another way to, you know, help
manipulate and move lymph. rebounding.
You guys, I love my rebounder. I don't
think I could go without it. And the
reason is is because I know how
important it is for our lymphatic
system. And our lymphatic systems are so
crucial to help us to stay healthy. And
so, like I said, most of the time, you
know, on our lymphatic system is until
we have a swollen lymph node that we
notice that there's, you know, something
wrong. And when I say something wrong,
you just have extra mucus. you got extra
toxins that your body can't get rid of.
Okay? So, when that happens, it causes a
disruption and it causes the body to
become stagnant. Okay? And it sort of
slows down other detoxification
pathways, especially like the liver. You
guys, the liver is crucial and it's the
most undertalked about largest organ,
one of the large. your skin is the
largest but your liver is second that
helps to detoxify
and increase you know those pathways and
so um they work tandem together and it's
important to understand that you know
detoxification is also part of the
lymphatic system. So the first thing
that the lymphatic system does it
removes waste and toxins from the body.
Another thing it does is it transports
the immune cells um to help fight
infection. And so it's also, you know,
sending the immune system signals. Plus,
it has good bacteria, okay, that's
helping the immune system. We're about
to in the United States, um, you know,
go into our flu and cold season. And so,
you know, we're about to go into, you
know, allergies and and, you know, the
leaves are starting to fall. We're
having beautiful weather here in in
Oklahoma. We're getting all this rain,
which is beautiful. um but we're about
to go into this season and so the
lymphatic system is going to play a big
part of your immune system. Okay. The
third thing is it also maintains fluid
balance by return returning excessive
fluid from tissues back into the
bloodstream. Okay. Why is this so
important? Well, you know, you might
know someone that has extra fluid that's
being retained in maybe the lower limbs.
Okay, extra fluid.
The lymphatic system is trying to get
rid of it. Okay, and so without having,
you know, like I said, it works with the
circulatory system as well as it works
with um the the Okay, so AJ, you already
got your hand up. Am I supposed to keep
going or do you need to say something?
Okay, keep going. Okay. Um, so it works
right with the circulatory system. And
so with that being said, you know, it's
really helping to get rid of that extra
fluid. And so that's also very
important. So the lymphatic system does
three things. And those three things are
key and very important. Okay. So here's
sort of a visual and this is why it's so
important to understand that it's your
lymphatic system is over your whole
body. Okay. And um and I the first you
know um shows the cervical lymph nodes.
It shows uh your tonsils. Um it shows
the thymus which really helps with our
temperature. You see how it's always you
know it's it's all around the organs and
also through the circulatory system is
running hand in hand beside it. Okay. To
try to remove these toxins. On the
second diagram you see that it really
affects the immune system. You can
really see where these lymph nodes,
which is in the green, can affect, you
know, different parts of our body. And
sometimes when we get them swelled up or
um they're stagnant, you know, they're
in areas that can cause, you know, a
destructive effect, okay? Because, you
know, it's just going to accumulate. And
so, you can see that the bone marrow is
affected. um you know there's you know
because it's always removing those
toxins that excessive waste working to
detoxify these certain key areas that
specific especially to our immune
system.
So, like I said, it's intriguing to me
because you have to have and here's a
lymphatic vessel, okay? The valve is
opening. Um, it overlaps the and the
full cells. Then you have the direction
that's flowing up. Well, that doesn't
even make sense. Okay? You know, the
blood flow comes down and it comes back
up to the heart, but the lymphatic
system has to have an upward flow. And
so when the valve closes and so I think
of it more like um uh you know well I
hate to bring a snake but you know that
snake whenever it eats something it's
always moving it down. Okay, think about
it coming the other direction. You know,
it has to move it, but it has this
movement flow. Okay, and the lymphatic
system does that. And so, it's always
trying to, you know, it opens it up,
gets the toxins out of the system, and
then it moves it up. It it does this,
you know, this continually, okay, over
your whole lymphatic system. So if you
have any, you know, cog in the wheel
that's not working properly, you're not
going to be able to remove those toxins
from those areas that need to have it
removed. Okay? So the lymphatic system
is crucial and having clean lymph. Okay?
Because um when you have viruses or you
don't have enough immunity um immune
cells, then it causes it to be stagnant.
Okay? So it's not bringing those out
because the lymph is so uh it's not
clear and it's not you know vibrant
because it's full of toxins. Okay. So we
have to remove those toxins and it
dissipates through the detoxification
pathways which the liver being one of
those um you know clears out that lymph
and it helps with the detoxification. So
you know you have to have that upward
motion to have the fluid to enter the
lymphatic capillaries. Okay. Now to the
right you can see you have your
arteries. Okay, now we're talking about
the circulatory system. Okay, you have
your lymphatic vessel and then you have
your veins. And so this is why these
work tandem together your circulatory
system and which is you know our blood
supply. So we have to have clean blood
to also to enhance that our lymphatic
system is not getting stagnant which is
to me is you know super incredible
especially whenever you look at you know
all over the body okay and you have all
these um parts of the lymphatic system
that are so closely related to the um
the immune system. You know your tonsils
your tonsils harbor good bacteria. Your
tonsils are a big part of your immune
system. When we get a sore throat, okay,
that means that our tonsils was being
overworked on having enough good
bacteria. Normally, sometimes people
don't have their tonsils, okay? Just
because you don't have your tonsils
doesn't mean um that you don't need good
healthy bacteria in this area to fight
off the bad bugs. Okay? The lymphatic
system, as you can see, um, on the left,
is right there to remove that lymph, to
remove those viruses, remove those to
toxins. Okay? We don't discover that we
have a sore throat until all of a sudden
we have pain in our lymph nodes. Okay,
that is associated with not having a
supercharged lymphatic system. letting
it flow like our title says. You know,
you want your lymph system and your
lymphatic system, you want healthy
lymph, which is just like a clear fluid
that gets circulatory, you know, cir,
you know, all throughout the system. Um,
you know, in the lower areas, that's
where a lot of times that's when we can
collect fluid. And, um, and so a lot of
people that have um problems, we work on
two things. You know, we work on the
lymphatic system to increase lymphatic
flow, but we also increase the
circulatory system because they work so
close together as you can see in the
right. Okay? They're they're so close
together that it's helping to remove
remove toxin. So, these are things that
are um very important to be aware of.
Okay? And so, what do we do? I mean
there's there's so many natural things
we we could do and um you know one of
the things of course is supplementation
and so I want to talk about this first
but then I want to talk in about foods
and um different therapies that we can
do because for people that know I mean
I'm a master herbalist nutritional
consultant um holistic health
practitioner um you know my latest you
know back in um 2019 is my naturopathic
degree But I get really excited with
ingredients and for, you know, Becca and
AJ, they know that I get a little bit
nerdy whenever it comes to the
ingredients because you guys, these
ingredients are so specific. Um, and so
it helps the lymphatic system and that's
what we're talking about today. So
there's, you know, certain medicinal
herbs, there are certain vitamins,
certain nutrients, um, that can help to
increase the lymphatic system. But like
I said, you can't outs supplement about
diet. You can't go without exercise. You
have to, you know, do different things
to also stimulate that. And the lady I
was talking to um yesterday, I mean,
she's doing everything. I mean, she's
doing because she is, you know, in the
fight of her life, especially whenever
it comes to her lymphatic system. And
so, you know, infrared saunas, hot
cotton cold treatments, which those are
different therapies, but supplementation
is a big part, but she is also not in
inundating her body with fried foods,
gluten, um you know, seed oils, uh you
know, dairy products that are heavy in
sugar. Okay. Um you know, dairy is okay,
but sugar also, you know, lowers the
immune system. S sugar sugar is actually
the worst thing you could put in your
body. So she's doing a lot of different
things and so but let's go back to
supplements. Okay, so the first one that
I wanted to talk about is the hope.
Okay, so the hope is a super blood
purifier. Okay, so why do I have it
combined with the lymphatic system?
Well, the lymphatic system is necessary
to keep the blood clean. Okay, can also
help the lymphatic system to stay clean.
Plus, you're detoxifying. So the hope
has a lot of detoxifying herbs like milk
thistle is in there. Um it has you know
sheep sorrel, it has um you know but it
has pelandula and it also has um boerdo
root. Okay. So when we come to like you
know parts of like the dandelion family
um the aster family it is very important
for the lymphatic system. So here's what
kellandulla does. It improves lymphatic
flow. Um, it reduces congestion and
supports the liver and the skin
detoxification. Now, I want you to
understand one word in there and that's
congestion. You guys, when you're just
feeling a little bit off, okay? You
know, you know, I just feel like, you
know, I'm not getting sick, but I sort
of feel like I might get sick. Go
stimulate your lymphatic system. You
guys, you're congested in your body
without the coughs and the sneezing and
all that kind of stuff. you're just
feeling a little bit off. Well, you need
to clean um your of your stagnant
congested lymphatic system. Okay. So,
one of the herbs that does that is the
berdock rit which is in the hope
product. Um another one that is uh well,
excuse me, the kalandula. And then
another one is the berdo rit. It is also
acts as a blood purifier but supports
detoxification through the lymphatic
system. You know, when you're when you
have a healthy detoxification pathway,
okay? you know which our lungs is a
detoxification pathway, our skin is a
detoxification pathway, our uh you know
our liver is a detoxification pathway.
It is taking toxins and trying to push
it through the lymphatic system and h
actually have it dissipate. So it's
important to have both of them run
together, okay, your detoxification
organs, okay, with the lymphatic system.
And so both of those are very important.
So berdock really works for that. Um and
also the kaland dulle which is
beautiful. Ginger is also an ingredient
that's in the hope product. Um it helps
to improve circulation, improves
inflammation and enhances lymphatic
flow. So you know so there's a lot of
you know the hope is a super blood
purifier but it's working like I said
together with the lymphatic system which
is beautiful. uh another product from a
new you know if you're familiar with
longevity I hope that you will get with
the person that brought you here or get
with a health coaches on here because
you guys longevity is the one-stop shop
okay and we just brought over a company
called life force and um longivity did
and they have um a lot of immunity
building products but one of these that
I'm super excited about is the Tahibbo
okay is got a p poda arco um in it and
that's all it has which is amazing.
Okay, this is a a medicinal herb that is
so powerful for the immune system but
also for the lymphatic system and it's
in a tincture which I like capsules and
tinctures um you know for medicinal
herbs and this is in a tincture but the
benefits is natural antifungal it's an
immune booster but it aids with with
lymphatic detoxification so it's an
incredible product to help you do that
um and you know and all of these I have
on the screen here can be taken
together, you guys. Especially if you're
I mean, none of these are overlapping
ingredients. Um, that's what's super
cool and that's where I get a little bit
excited because I, like I said, I love
ingredients. Um, and so, but we got the
good herbs. The next product, it is uh
um specifically for lymphatic health,
but like I said, it doesn't um overlap
any ingredients. It's got organ grape um
which is a beautiful ingredient. And I
have that also in my um stay clear
product with the stay natural line but
I'm didn't focus it on here but it's got
organ grape. It's got the mullen leaf
you guys. Mullen leaf especially for
congestion is beautiful. I mean I love
to harvest you know the the mullen leaf.
I mean a lot of people you know will go
and harvest it and it's really good for
colds uh you know flu you know different
things like that. Um but you don't have
to do that. It's in the lymphatic
health. We don't have to do that. I just
do it for fun. because I know I'm going
to take the lymphatic health supportive
product from the good herbs line. Okay.
Um but you know it has you know several
ingredients um medicinal herbs that
helps with the lymphatic flow. Let it
flow. Okay. No more congestion. When I
say that will this keep you from being
sick? No. Okay. There's other factors
that goes into that but why not have a
supercharged lymphatic system? Okay. And
that's what I'm talking about. These are
going to increase your lymphatic flow.
Okay. Um, which is important. Zradle is
another super blood purifier. It does
other things. It also has
anti-inflammatory benefits to it. Um,
but it has a lot of the super uh C
products which you know vitamin C is
crucial whenever it comes to the
lymphatic system. Um, which is uh also
incredible whenever it comes to that. Um
and so Zerdical is another, you know,
great product to help us with that. Stay
young is also um a super product to help
uh you know, it's it's stronger than
vitamin C. Okay, it's got citrus
bioflavonoids, hesperdine complex. Both
of those are combined to be stronger
than vitamin C. when we and I'm sure for
everybody that's on here, okay, what's
the first thing we run to whenever we
start getting snipples and we go get our
vitamin C, you know, we've been taught
that as kids, you know, u we go eat an
orange or, you know, whatever it is,
we've been taught that. Okay, so it is
true. Vitamin C. Vitamin C does so many
things, but I like getting it from um
you know instead of you know taking a
vitamin C tablet, I like getting it from
the actual u you know sources of the
vitamin C and that's where that citrus
boflavonoids and the the hesperine
complex which theodine complex is when
you have your orange or your lemon or
your lime. Okay. Um you know you have
the outer rind which we get the extracts
the citrus boflavonoids from but the
inner um pith of the the the white part
is the hesperdime. Okay that's actually
the pith of the fruit is where we get
hesperdime and so my sister I guess I'm
going to tell her she would always eat
the rind of of the oranges and the
lemons. I'm like what are you doing? She
goes I just I don't know. I like it. and
she was, you know, she was probably
deficient in vitamin C and her body was
naturally having her do that. Um, but,
you know, she I don't remember her
getting sick very often. And so, I don't
recommend you don't have to go eat um,
you know, the rind of a fruit, but you
can take stay young and you're getting,
you know, the same, but you're getting
an instruction. So, um, say young is a
super antioxidant, you guys.
Antioxidants fight free radicals, which
free radicals are, you know, um, you
know, the environment that we live in,
you know, we can't get away from things
that come into our bloodstream, okay,
that shouldn't be there. And so free
radicals, when you take an antioxidant,
which these next two products that stay
young, the cell shield RTQ, these are
two powerhouse, not duplicating
ingredients. Like I said, you can take
them together, but they're super
powerhouses whenever it comes to
fighting those free radicals. I mean, it
is amazing. And so, you have to think of
it like a Pac-Man, you know, that goes
in and it just gobbles up all those
foreign things that's in the
bloodstream. Okay. Well, back to
lymphatic health, okay? It's also doing
the same thing. It's trying to keep the
lymph clean and pure. And so whenever
your body is faced with some invader
because that's what the lymphatic system
also does is it sends the immune system
the right cells you know to to defend
itself from these foreign um bacterias
foreign uh you know fungi or you know
whatever the foreign matter is is going
to defend it. Okay. So when you have
super antioxidants that also helps to
have a clean running machine and so um
you know the stay young the cell shield
RTQ um which you know the cell shield
RTQ has also like the Japanese knotweed
um it has uh rodeiola which is an
adaptogen I mean it's just another
beautiful product that I like um but
these are my top ones specifically now
now if you're joining me I'm not telling
you these are vitamins and minerals in
our nine essential nutrients. Absolutely
not. You take your nine essential
nutrients, okay, which are which is our
key products. It still is is giving you
a functioning immune system and it's
helping you with your lymphatic system
because this is such amazing products,
but these are extra ones that you can
add to it to have, you know, just a
really, you know, you know, I just think
about um Tron. I don't know why that
came to my mind. I really don't think
about Tron. But, you know, I think
about, you know, him and and when he had
to fight and he had on this metal and
and he had on this all this gear and he,
you know, he was he could fight off
anything or even like Wonder Woman, you
know, she was just batting, you know,
uh, you know, she could fight off
anything, lasers, you know, Spider-Man,
um, you know, all that kind of thing. I
want to have a superhero immune system,
lymphatic system, and detoxification
system because then whenever I go
outside, I don't have to worry about
what I'm coming in contact with because
I had this strong immune system. I had
the strong lymphatic system. I had the
strong detoxification pathway. Knock on
wood, I cannot remember the last time I
got sick. I'm not saying you're not
going to get sick. I'm just saying
let's, you know, be that Wonder Woman.
Let's be, you know, Superman. Let's do
Tron. I mean, let's have that armor that
we need to have the best defense. And
doing that, I mean, you is one of the
things is is supplementation, which is,
you know, beautiful. Okay. Now, I'm
going to talk about some other things
that helps the lymphatic system. But
here here's some here's some symptoms of
why your lymphatic system would be
stagnant or or here's some symptoms. And
so, really think about this, okay? Do
you get frequent colds or infections?
Do your wounds not heal? Okay, you know,
wound not healing, okay, is means that
your immune system is suppressed, but
also you don't have a full functioning
lymphatic system. You're not getting
enough to that area. Puffy face or
swollen lymph nodes. Well, lymph nodes,
you know, usually is a given. I mean, we
can feel them, but you know, guys, we
have lymph nodes everywhere, okay? We
have them under, you know, our arms. We
have them in our groins. We have them in
our stomach. There's limp nodes in other
areas. And so just because you have you
don't have pain up here in your neck,
but you might have pain underneath your
arm or, you know, somewhere you could
have a swollen lip node um in other
places. My daughter in Georgia, she's a
wonderful nurse and she got a swollen
lymph node in her groin. It never had
happened before. Now, she has um an an
autoimmunity, but she, you know, got a
virus after her second child was born.
And so, she her immunity, she always has
to stay on top of it. Well, she had this
swollen lymph node um in her groin. She
said it was the most painful thing she
had ever felt. And so, you know,
immediately, you know, she calls and you
know, immediately she's, you know,
hitting, you know, the vitamin C. She
even um you know, put castor oil packs.
Castor oil packs are amazing whenever it
comes to inflammation. We have a super
powerful uh essential oil line, okay,
that you can also ask your health coach,
you know, to help you um understand if
you want to put something topically on.
Okay. Um but another symptom is water
retention or swollen hands and feet.
Okay. Relate that to your lymphatic
system. Okay. Let's start working on it
first. fatigue or brain fog. Who would
have thought? Um, you know, brain fog or
fatigue would be because of my lymphatic
system. I mean, who would have thought
that?
Skin issues like acne or rashes. Okay,
those are all symptoms that can come
from having a congested or sluggish or,
you know, uh, stagnant lymphatic system.
Okay. So, there's things that we got to
do. um you know your sympa lymphatic
system is the bridge between
detoxification your immune system and a
healthy blood circulation. So just know
that okay it's the bridge okay think of
it you know because sometimes we focus
just on the circulatory system okay
sometimes we focus just on the
detoxification system your lymphatic
system is the bridge between the
detoxification immune system your immune
defense um and your healthy blood
circulation okay now here's some natural
things that uh that I like to also um
give my clients to help support their
healthy lymphatic system. One is
hydration.
Okay. And let me just go down to this.
Uh Whoops, I got stuck. Am I stuck? No.
Okay, there we go. Wh I went past. Okay,
here's some natural things that you can
do. Okay. Uh one, you can go get a
manual lymphatic massage drainage, and
there is experts out there that can do
it. There's also
um where you can, you know, learn how to
massage your lymph nodes yourself. Okay?
I don't suggest you need to get a
YouTube video that, you know, from an
expert that actually shows you how to do
that. Okay? Um but one is is hydration.
You got to have half of your body
weights in ounces of purified water. And
I always suggest that when you wake up,
you have a room temperature water
sitting on the counter. So, I always
fill mine up before I go to bed. And
when I get up, I go to the sink, I cut
my fresh lemon, and I squeeze it in
there and I drink it. That's the first
thing I do. It aids in digestion. It
aids in detoxification and it's trying
to work as a clearing house of what was
stored the night before. Okay, so that's
one good thing that is is important to
do. Next is movement, you guys.
Exercise, like walking. Um, of course,
running. I don't like to run unless
somebody's chasing me probably. Um, but
I am not a runner. I love to walk in
nature. Um, I will admit that. But I
love rebounding, you guys. I have a mini
mini trampoline and um and you know,
when I put up my Christmas tree, I had
to move it out of the living room so
it's in my my uh bedroom. But you know,
I do seven minutes in the morning. I do
seven minutes in the afternoon or
evening. Okay, you guys. Three minutes
of rebounding stimulates your lymphatic
system to where you're clearing out.
Remember how I said that you have to
have an upward motion for lymph. You
want to increase it. And so the way you
do that is you got to stay active. Okay.
Um you know so walking, rebounding,
stretching, okay, stretching also
increases lymphatic action. Uh dry
brushing. Okay. There is uh and I can
send you information on that if you want
to send me an email. Um, and I can
actually send you these suggested tips.
So, if you just want to email, I can
send this to you for free as well. Uh,
castor oil packs, uh, they help to
reduce congestion and also support
detox. I'm a big fan of castor oil. I
love that. I love mixing our essential
oils with the castor oil. Um, which is I
mean, it's just oh my gosh, it's
amazing. Okay, top foods, leafy greens.
Okay, green leafy greens. And I, you
know, when I think about green food like
spinach, kale, um, cabbage, um, I think
about regulating pH in the body, okay?
And you guys, pH is necessary to re
reduce congestion, okay? And so those
are top crucifery vegetables, berries,
lemons, garlic, ginger, pumpkin seeds,
chia seeds, bone broth, um, which we
have so much good, uh, you know, protein
and collagen, which is so good whenever
it comes to that as well. Bonus
therapies are infrared sauna and Epsom
salt baths, uh, manual lymphatic
drainage like right here, and also the
supplements like we were talking about.
Um, you know, these are all very
important for the lymphatic system. And
here's some extra products just to take
a snapshot because I'm not going to go
over them, but these are all, you know,
Steniz Plus contains licorice. Licorice
also is very, um, lymphatic um, forward.
Um, it also has adaptogens. It helps
with circulation, helps with focus. Uh,
core AO is another super antioxidant.
Youngevity's Herbal Rainforest, you
guys. This is a detoxification,
mineral, and vitamin. It's I take herbal
rainforest every single day. Whether I
feel like I need a detox or not, I love
the herbal rainforest. I mean, but I
love herbs. Okay, so maybe because it
says herbal on the front, I don't know.
Um, the megas, you know, the EFAs, you
guys, for inflammation. Um,
and I put the distress on here because
you guys, stress,
um, causes us to tense up. Okay, think
about our lymph nodes. Okay, if you're
continuously
stressed,
how can you have a lymphatic system
that's trying to get the lymphatic flow?
When I showed you the diagram of where
all the lymph nodes are, okay? When
you're stressed, when you, you know,
you're just tense, you guys, that
creates a congestion in the body, okay?
Breathing exercises, stretching, you
know, you have to be able to figure out
where that stress is coming from and do
things more that bring you joy. Okay, I
am going to close out my stop my screen
share
and um
Okay, I hope I enlightened everyone
about their lymphatic system, how
crucial and important um it is. It's you
guys. And it's at least like like Becca
said when when she says, "Oh, I want
that topic." Because we never talk about
it. We need to talk about it. Okay, we
need to talk about it. You know, we need
to draw it out from detoxification,
immune system. I because I try to cover
all of them. We might have to do a
three-part series. I'm not sure, but
it's so
>> Let's do it. I mean, I'm
>> Let's Let's geek out on those
ingredients.
>> Oh, yeah.
>> I love it.
>> I love it. I love it. You know, and a
lot of other people are loving it, too.
Um, they love how you keep your slides
up long enough that they can actually
see what's on the slide and read all of
the things. So, I definitely want to get
that slide that shows the lymphatic
system. also the one with all of the
alternative things that you can do to
help yourself like the lymphatic
drainage which I was really I was really
excited because I have never done
lymphatic drainage before and I had set
up an appointment with Tim Marsh and his
his crew to have it done
and Melissa's like don't need it like
so then that's a good thing Right?
Whenever they tell you you don't need
lymphatic drainage because that means
things are moving the way they're
supposed to.
>> That's really good.
>> But there's so much more that we can do
even I mean supporting it. You don't
want to just say, "Oh, I don't need any
of that stuff." You want to continually
support your body and every single
function.
Every single function. So, we do have
some questions. We have lots of
comments. Um, Olga says, "I drink lemon
water, squeezed whole lemon in a glass
of lukewarm water first thing in the
morning, and I take two capsules of
Ultimate Enzymes with it." What does Dr.
Laura think about it?
>> I think that's great because the
Ultimate Enzymes, okay, especially taken
on an empty stomach, is going to also
try to remove the trash that's been
held, but it's it's it's more of doing
it just from the stomach aspect. Okay,
the lemon water is going to take
everything throughout the whole body and
and the enzymes will make it there too,
but they have to go through digestion.
Lemon water, you know, is more
purification and works as more of a
detoxification. But yes, those two can
be taken together. Those are great. And
you guys, with um why I do lemon water
by itself or even apple cider vinegar,
you guys, apple cider vinegar is another
one that you could, you know, put in to
help that detoxification. So,
I have to dilute a lot of the apple
cider vinegar for me. I mean, just
because that's just me. But, you know,
that works also to help to detoxify. And
you guys, you will have when you first
started Olga, and I know you've been
doing it, so you probably already
experienced it, but you guys, if it if
it does a clean out, you guys don't
worry about it. Your body needed to get
rid of it. Okay? So, if you drink it and
then all of a sudden you're going to
make your coffee and you have to run to
the bathroom, guess what? Your body
needed to get rid of that. Okay? So,
don't be alarmed. Don't think it's a
laxative or something. It's trying to do
exactly that. Get rid of it.
>> Absolutely.
Now, um Barbara has a question. Can
anything be done for someone who has had
lymphatic issues since birth?
>> Okay. So since birth is a little bit
hard because they've been you know not
handicapped but they've been held back
to do extra things that could increase
their lymphatic system like movement.
Okay. Um you know I think about um
extreme conditions with lymphatic leg uh
you'll see uh you know the elephant leg
syndrome or you'll see you know heavy
heavy edema and so yes do I always I
always think there's we can always
improve we can all you know we may not
cure something but we can always improve
and so even doing the supplementation
that we were talking about changing the
diet to to um you to support the immune
system and not take away because you
guys what we eat you have to say to
yourself am I putting it in is it going
to help my body or is it going to
destroy it. Okay. So cleaning up the
diet, understanding, you know, what they
need to help
and then all the alternative therapies,
you know, the lymphatic drainage. Okay.
Um, infrared saunets, which infrared is
a very u neat alternative therapy that
can help people especially that don't
have a lot of movement. Okay? you know
that they're more um not veteran or
anything like that because I'm sure this
person since birth it's not that um but
he's just been held back he or her and
so yes there's always and so I would put
them on this regimen I would you know do
the alternative therapies reach out on
my email I'll send you the free list of
you know supportive alternative
therapies um that can actually help
increase and improve
>> awesome fantastic and I'm glad that you
mentioned infrared saunas us because I
mentioned to my partner yesterday like,
you know, I'd really like to get an
infrared sauna and now I can use this
show to support that.
>> Oh, absolutely.
>> Super excited about that. Um, now so for
for those of you who don't know on
YouTube, AJ does a poll,
okay?
And
you have two choices.
It is unanimous.
Yes, Dr. Dennison is back. Woo! Instead
of no, lymphatic system is fake news.
That has 0%. So, we've got a smart
audience, Dr. Laura.
>> That is awesome. I'm so glad that I
mean, it's a little scary what AJ can
put up on there, I'm sure. And so, I'm
glad it was clean and and you didn't ask
very personal questions and take a poll
on me. Okay.
>> Absolutely. Absolutely. So, let's go to
AJ with a question.
>> Dr. Laura, it is fantastic to see you.
Thank you for being here. And I do have
more questions than we have time for.
Um, but two of them you you touched on.
I need some clarification.
So, what toxins disrupt our lymphatic
system? You mentioned sugar, you
mentioned oils. Can you just uh give us
some more on that one? And I guess the
>> the second the second part of what you
already discussed was you mentioned
edema, swollen ankles. I got a friend
that wears a red tie, has orange hair,
he's got swollen ankles. I was wondering
if you had some insight as to what might
be occurring there.
>> Okay. Okay. So, you guys um Okay. Okay,
I'm so glad that you mentioned that, AJ,
because I didn't clarify. I just
mentioned foods, you guys. There's so
much other things that disrupts the
lymphatic system. Okay, one is unhealthy
bacteria. So, fungi, mold, um you know,
not having a healthy gut, okay, can also
cause uh the lymphatic system not to be
properly running. But these toxins that
we breathe in, okay, you have to think
about the detoxification pathways, your
skin, your um your uh your lungs, your
organs, you know, as far as you know,
your um so our digestive tract, you
know, that goes with foods especially,
okay? and not having enough healthy
bacteria. But even things that we put on
our body like soaps and and endocrine
disruptors, toxins, sprays, uh what we
spray on our carpet, these are all
chemicals that's going into our body
that are toxins. These are free radicals
in our lymphatic system. Sort of, you
know, it's it's got the little spy
glass. Okay, this is what a lymphatic
system thinks makes me think of. It's
got the little spy glass and it's going
through the body and it's looking at all
the organs and you know give me your
toxins, okay, and trying to remove it
out of the body, okay? Well, when our
body is stagnant, our liver holds on to
toxins, our, you know, tonsils or, you
know, our our upper area holds on to
toxins and so the lymphatic system goes
in and tries to remove those. So
anything that's foreign, anything that
and we can get it from anything. I mean,
you know, from what we put on our skin
to how we shampoo our hair to hair
coloring, you know, all these
environmental poisons goes in the body
and is a toxin. If your body is not if
it's stagnant or congested, it's going
to hold on to those toxins. they'll get
placed into the fat cells in the body
and all of a sudden you are, you know, a
soup of all these toxins, okay, that
that your body's been trying to get rid
of. When you have a healthy lymphatic
system, it is just beautiful. And when
you have just like Becca said, she goes
and and she goes for a lymphatic
drainage and and he's like, "Man, your
your lymph nodes look pretty good."
Well, she's been working really hard at
staying healthy. And so, you know,
that's one of the key things. Okay, so
that was your first question. And your
second question, go ahead and repeat
that. I apologize.
>> Okay. Well, part of that same question
is, so what happens if the lymphatic
system doesn't drain? I mean, you
touched on it, but is there a particular
disease that can come from that? I'm I'm
I'm steering you here.
>> Okay. Okay. So, so the you cannot relate
everything back to a disease with the
lymphatic system. Okay. It's trying to
remove toxins. But what happens is those
toxins get settled. Okay? Let's talk
about edema, okay? Swelling of the feet
and and and the lower limbs, okay? It's
in the derma layer of the the skin,
okay? It can't get rid of the fluid. So,
the lymphatic system wasn't working
properly and now it's storing all this
these toxins in the in the edema in the
dermal layer of the skin. Okay? If the
lymphatic system is is working properly,
it's going to try to remove those and
get it moved up through the lymph and it
dissipates in the body. It gets rid of
it, okay? Through the liver, um you
know, through feces, um there's, you
know, whatever detoxification pathway we
have, it's getting rid of it, okay? And
so, um so you have to have a good
lymphatic system to be able to u make
sure that you're not getting these
toxins stored that do increase to a
disease. So my friend with the orange
hair and the red tie is probably got a
poor lymphatic system.
>> Correct.
Yes. And so but you work on
detoxification. Okay. All the herbs, all
the different vitamins, minerals, and
everything as well as working on the
lymphatic system. Those two are key
things, you know, to be able to work
together.
>> I didn't mean to cut you off. Were you
done?
>> Yes.
>> Okay. So my second question is um on all
your bottles, your products, it says
Genesis 1:29,
uh God said, "Behold, I have given you
every herb uh bearing seed." I'm sure
you could quote it better than me,
bearing seed, which is upon the face of
the earth, and every tree in which the
fruit of a tree yielding seed to you. It
shall be for your food or for me to
thank. Where do you grow your herbs? Why
did you put this on your bottles?
>> Okay. So, we are and I'm so thankful.
AJ, I just want to crawl in there and
give you a big old hug because you guys,
this was so important for us when we
came over with Young Jevity because it
was such a powerful Genesis 129 for us
to put on the label because these are
medicinal herbs that God gave us, okay?
From seeds to the trees to the plants.
When you think about that, okay, in in
the translation it says